predict with magnus i mean i was like i
i i don't know basically i have no idea
there you go
how can you how can you predict that i
mean you'd have to be
nostradamus mark two to get that one
right i mean uh d3 a really strange move
so he's played he's open with c3 now d3
uh three next maybe e3 is gonna be next
he's played b3 c3 d3 e3 f3 g3 on the
tour just this season
i remember i remember talking to vidit
when he was playing in the men's world
championship before and how how much he
respects magnus carlsen how much he's
meant to him being just four years
younger trying to with the whole
background of a non and then he comes
out and he throws d3 at you after you
probably prepared quite a lot what does
that do to you yeah it throws you off
and imagine vidit has spent nearly one
minute thinking of his reply on move one
uh
it's definitely psychologically it's uh
it's not easy to bounce back and vid it
he'll need to just play quickly just
trust his instincts occupy the center
follow the general opening rules but
when you're playing the world champion
when you know that he's kind of
freestyling when he's uh kind of
just uh throwing these weird wacky ideas
against you it is hard and okay we've
transposed into a sicilian and you're
happy that simon i i'm happy about this
because it's a chessable course um uh
is it yes it is brilliant i love it so
we're out of your simon it is the grand
prix isn't it it's it's kind of grand
prix yeah this this actually came out as
a course that myself and uh richard
palace did for chesapeal uh richard is a
very strong uh international master
brilliant player and a brilliant
theoretician but this is this was called
the british grand prix because a lot of
british players were playing this
particular setup that white goes for and
um it it's
getting out of theory so it's doing the
kind of thing that i think magnus
likes doing you're not into any real
deep theory and you can get often very
good attacking chances luke machine won
a fantastic game in this um against
chaparrinov going back to i think 2009
2009
it was in the european team
championships and it was kind of a kind
of a
group kind of yeah the funniest thing
the funny story about this is why it was
called the british grand prix it could
there's some other players who could be
named after as well was that we're
basically sitting around um the
restaurant having some wine
discussing some ideas and uh it was
stewart conquest it was myself it was uh
luke mcshane mickey adams and stephen
gordon and we're just thinking why why
don't you put the bishop on this square
that magnus put it to in the grand prix
getting like a reversed good dutch
opening because in the normal grand prix
you put the bishop on the other side of
the pawns but it gets kicked around a
lot and with this simple move we're
thinking okay this this is actually very
very interesting you can castle you can
swing the white queen and maybe david
can put some uh little arrows on the
board swing the white queen
over towards the king side if you want
to and it's like okay and we thought
yeah this is really interesting it
avoids a lot of theory you get a
position these two pawns in the middle
they're very very nice uh as well and uh
yeah and then basically luke won this
incredible game in 20 moves of it so uh
i'm obviously excited to see it because
it was one of the most recent courses
that i made and it's an opening i've
played
quite a lot myself as well yeah the
whole idea is that if black does attack
at some point he comes
yeah exactly if black does castle sorry
then you can attack him you throw pawns
forward you bring your bishop out and
i mean you're basically a fortune teller
simon because the white queen has indeed
slid across one square she's heading for
this square now the h4 is exciting about
this you know what it is
does he learn that from his festival
correspondent
yeah and i've had this position myself
luke had this position against tripori
2009 and the reason i love this position
is you can be an absolute lunatic and
i'd love to see magnus be a lunatic and
just throw everything at the black king
i mean david again you can show the
ideas here where the queen might go it's
a very simple pattern here um let's say
black does nothing the queen comes over
to this square um getting nearer the
black king let's say black does some
stuff on the queen side and now a lovely
move here you push the f pawn and then
let's say black keeps doing stuff on the
queen side now the bishop flies in
getting rid of a defender of the black
king black continues ignoring it
probably not very wise and now the white
knight comes into the position and you
already have some uh very very dangerous
threats here maybe even a winning
position for the white house now simon
oh well if this if this happens i'll be
here by the course the british grand
prix it's uncheckable it's a blooming
good course and there's a free one-hour
version yeah look at this pawn chain uh
it's also white going to try and crash
through on this square for example if
black continues then you do have ideas
of trading and yes the black knight
covers the square but you can remove
this black knight by capturing a pawn
sacrificing attacking and yeah it's all
about the black king in the current
position it's magnus to play
okay he brings his knight out first
slightly surprising he didn't rush to
bring his queen into the attack this one
logical as well the white knight on the
decent square
more centralized and yeah let's watch
out for the black king will it come
under fire with those ideas that simon
highlighted i have one question about
this
very often people have referred to
magnus carlsen as being extremely
calculated at least some points of his
career how he plays like a computer he
plays computer moves does he have the
mania required to play this position and
does he have that maniac side in him
that's an interesting question because
he is i would say a very mature player
as in he doesn't normally like throwing
all his eggs into one basket he's not an
all-in player by any means when he plays
so
i don't know if he's going to throw
everything towards the black king and
you can see here the maneuver that he's
done is another very normal maneuver but
vidic's last move i think is very wise
because you want to swap off that white
knight which we saw can be a very
powerful attacking piece so i expect he
won't go for that all in approach he'll
take it a little bit more calm but i
still like white's position because
there's two pawns uh there over on the
king's side in the middle i think magnus
does have that in his locker the kind of
mania side uh the kind of pure all-out
attacker but the thing is he doesn't
need to use it that often normally he
can simply grind players down smoothly
without taking any risk at all
but maybe in a situation now where he's
pretty confident he's going to qualify
for the knockouts he might start to take
risks he might start to kind of play for
the crowd
kind of play for the beauty prize as we
say interests and uh yeah simon i'm
still watching out for that attacking uh
idea coming on the board as you've said
black is doing a good job black's knight
in the center of the board now a strong
piece he can trade a set of knights if
necessary but for example if the black
knight in the middle of the board takes
the white knight now that only helps
white white's rook might lift up the
board and swing across later
yeah plenty of ideas and vivid clearly
is outside of his comfort zone and
normally in terms of openings
that's uh that's the only thing you can
hope for these days yeah i mean one of
the reasons i think this is a very good
way to play against the sicilian in
general is that you know
it's the same kind of patterns you just
learn some certain patterns you don't
have to memorize so much theory and it
takes your opponent into positions that
they're they're not comfortable with and
you can see as you say vidit here maybe
not as comfortable in such a position
with the black pieces i mean i think
what black january should be doing here
is try to make some exchanges of those
dangerous pieces and then start the
queenside play this move here just
moving the bishop once it's very slow
move that one uh i mean that is
i really love to see magnus going to
turbo drive now uh will he will he swing
the queen over would he even play a pawn
sack fight here it comes here it
and
yeah i can tell you that white has an
incredible score here you know it looks
so dangerous so surprisingly it isn't
isn't any surprise but i was a little
bit nervous for because for a long time
um i could just see that
in the database there was a jay
housekeeper playing this position with
the black pieces but it was not me i
hated to say
there's another j house girl it's a yuri
yeah and yeah he's from the czech
republic so hello
and uh yeah it's very good because uh
very having a name doppelganger because
when people try to search you up on the
database they get their game this
person's games as well i was thinking
one one year i was trying to the british
championships mickey adams was
the top seed and i thought maybe we
could get the top 10 players that will
change their name by depol to mickey
adams just to confuse the arbiters so
you'd have mickey adams versus mickey
adams mickey adams versus mickey adams
and they get all the preparation no one
will know who they're playing and then
you change it back afterwards it's a
really stupid idea isn't it quite
expensive though to change it's just a
stupid idea but it sounded quite funny
to do but yeah no it's a stupid idea
i've known a few players who've done
that just so that they wouldn't be
findable in the databases already so
it's not possible to find their names
and i know when i was young a lot of the
top chinese players um you know they
would maybe different spellings every
tournament and um okay meanwhile the
black bishop has jumped out but that's
the second time in a row that that black
bishop has just moved
surprising a lot of time for vidit it
shows that he's clearly uncomfortable
with the kind of incoming attack
but losing a move losing an important
tempo in a position like this where the
attack is about to happen
that
it's not that logical
so okay he wants to get rid of this
white knight you're the expert here
simon what do you think should white
just kind of sit before kind of going
all out for the attack or should white
uh maybe build up for it is now the
moment to go forward with some pawns
yeah yeah i mean i i yeah i mean i think
in general black's plan this idea of
putting the knight in the center and the
bishop over there is one of black's best
plans because he wants to exchange off
the pieces i mean magnus's moving the
queenside night out is not that normal
because you want to be able to push a
pawn to the square where the white
knight is this is one of the key key
ideas of this system you put a pawn on
this square which should be a lovely
move if magnus could play that now so
i'm not sure the knight really wants to
be there but yeah why not push the pawn
here i mean and go for it uh the only
issue with that is as david's your show
if black now plays bishop takes knight
you you kind of have to do this strange
thing i think and probably take your
pawn i say probably
um you could yeah this this is a little
bit weird this position if you take with
your bishop i guess the downside is that
this pawn might drop off um you no
longer protect this pawn and your rook
is under fire we actually saw something
very similar to this position yesterday
uh in a game between gawain jones and
pregnant but meanwhile magnus didn't
choose to launch pawns forward and go
all out for the attack yet
first he traded a set of knights and
after this recapture white can actually
take this black bishop off the board but
it does come at the cost of your own
knight and here after for example pawn
takes knight
you can't really get greedy as white you
can't win a pawn at the moment because
after more trades firstly you will never
get an attack if pieces come off the
board but secondly the black bishop can
restore the balance
and maybe even some stronger moves there
for black in the process magnus decided
no more exchanges and uh in the current
position instead of taking this bishop
as we just showed he dropped his knight
back temporarily at least i don't like
white's minor pieces
these pieces are kind of clumsy in the
way
but temporarily maybe some ideas of
going after this
pawn in the center of the board and
black doesn't have any kind of
necessarily aggressive active ideas of
his own so if white does get given the
time still this idea will be on the
board yeah i mean i think this is why i
bring the white knight out as magnus
done and i mean it is
not the way you normally play the
position at least because i might even
want the white knight back on its
starting square
in a lot of structures and there you can
see
yeah and vid it here now creating
counter play on the c file and i i would
actually say that fidd has probably done
a good job here of uh
stopping any dangerous attack at least
this is the one retreating that's not a
good sign for the world champion
suddenly things are turning in black's
favor and
i think you're right simon he should
have bought your chestable course he
should have been watching because this
white knight is in the way
he kind of owns chess ball he should he
should kind of watch your course if he's
going to play the opening you know
so he's only got himself to blame hasn't
he yeah but i have to say you know i
still think the position isn't that easy
for reddit i don't think vidit has
necessarily fully equalized because
there's still questions to answer how
are you going to defend the pawn
i mean i would just snap this knight off
without thinking too much maybe now
white's queen has to take the white
bishop has to stay defending this pawn
and now i mean the knight can reroute
black's queen can come out
it's very hard to attack for white uh
without that this is the knights it's
such a key idea that black's done here
to get rid of that white knight on the
king side that white knight can be so
dangerous i mean you can of course do
this rook swinging idea um in a lot of
cases in that last line that david
showed but you haven't got many pieces
now to attack and i think it will be
more more slower slower sort of play
here yep so magnus not going for the
all-out checkmate disappointing but
still a very rich position in store and
okay in the current position um he
didn't take off white tonight i'm
slightly surprised he brought his queen
out instead
so i don't think white should get greedy
and snap off this pawn for example if
you take this pawn with your knight
right now then there will be tactics
such as knight takes pawn attacking the
white queen but more importantly
unleashing this bishop and for example
after a trade here black actually wins
the white queen due to a pin so white
still has to be very careful don't be
greedy don't be hasty magnus just uh
forcing actually this trade bishop for
night it's gonna be a long maneuvering
game ahead
yeah certainly and uh whilst video is
contemplating whether to capture that
night or not i suspect he will do it as
david mentioned
well we have our quiz of the day where
we're asking very simple question what
is your chat level and uh you all at
home are giving us creative answers and
uh bishop takes knight on the board and
i really do have to say i like chama
kurpu's uh answer who says that their
chest level is relatively speaking like
a boxer who throws all the punches in
the first round i.e the opening
then spends the rest of the rounds the
middle game the end game running around
the ring and holding the opponent's arms
that's a very good tweet that is very
very nice
and
daniel nolan actually transfers the
question back to us and says i'm
definitely a positional player any tips
on becoming more attacking
play sharper openings
through the games of simon williams yeah
also play the king's indian
get the lifetime repertoires yeah
but it is it is i mean if you want to
sharpen up your game and i one thing i
find again or like let's say take the
english chess scene a lot of players who
play who've been playing for like 20 30
years but they're not improving they're
all around they're all around like 2100
and i don't understand what they're
doing because they play the same
openings the same setups they're not
getting better so you know you've got to
change things up and if you're playing
the same setups it's a really good idea
to suddenly change and play some really
sharp stuff you might lose a lot of
games but you just got to try to do
something different and uh picking
sharper openings will give you
a sharper game as simple as that and
that's the thing i mean that's a great
tweet great question but it also depends
what your goals are if your goals are to
become the most effective player it's
all about results then embrace your
style just
look for players look for top players
who have your style choose openings that
kind of complement that but uh yeah if
you're playing for enjoyment just want
to attack want to change things up for
the sake of changing things up then yeah
switch the openings um definitely play
through the games of attacking players
and will the h pawn move now sorry
this is this is another little idea that
we talked about in in the chesapeake
course uh best of british and you know
one thing i think is very important for
chess courses is not just talk about the
opening moves but talk about some
standard ideas that you should try in
the middle game and this idea might look
strange but whenever your opponent has a
fee in chateau pawn as black has here um
you can try you can try attacking that
especially when you've got more pressure
on that side of the board so the idea of
pushing the h pawn is is a good idea
funnily enough white's queen side is
pretty solid over there it's very hard
for black to do anything i know white
doesn't have great development well oh
he's gone the other way
to say this because i was 100 sure it
wasn't even a question my mind that
magnus would push this pawn it's just a
magnus move he does this all the time
and he loves his rook lifts
i commentated on the candidates with him
last year and
every possible position even if it made
no sense he would want to lift up his
rook and slide it across
not even to attack just for positional
purposes i love that actually see i'm
learning something as well from watching
this because i'm only looking at the
king but this idea it looks very nice i
think he's going to try and combine it
later on um i think it's also very
clever that you waited for this kind of
signal this trigger that the black
knight retreated away from the black
king and then you want to launch your
pawn forward i think that's definitely
viable but what magnus is doing really
instructive actually because this white
rook in the corner just two moves ago
look at it it's boxed in it's stuck it's
got nowhere to go suddenly push a pawn
um sorry push this pawn forward black
blocks and lifting the rook up suddenly
the rook has an easy path to an outpost
actually if it gets to this b5 square
then it's going to be a glorious piece
so did it try to stop that but
now the black knight is getting in the
way if anything and now it's completely
offside it's never going to go to the
king's side or the right side of the
board so simon says simon is it now time
is it now or never i mean it makes a lot
of sense to concentrate on that area
aboard because you know black's only got
the bishop defending and you've already
got the other white pawns uh you don't
need to put you know rush pushing those
pawns you can do but why not try to
soften up black's position as much as
you can first and this typical idea
putting that pawn on that square and
then putting the queen behind it again
at the right moment can be very
dangerous um maybe of a rook swinging
around later on yeah for example if
black just kind of sits and does nothing
bring the queen forward and the other
plan you mentioned simon lifting both
the rooks up the board this rook's
already lifted to the third rank now you
lift this one up and across and you try
and break through
towards the black king very tempting
very logical yeah and uh what about my
favorite thing in the world david
you know it is very very visual you know
if there's a if there's a pawn on the h4
you know maybe there should be four
pawns on the fourth row okay so uh
rather than pushing forward i'm not sure
what this pawn is doing apart from
getting in the way for white and
weakening white's king but it looks
special
i was thinking maybe freddy freddy can
go and come forward
you know
yeah push them all why not you know get
them all rolling up the board so
it looks pretty scary doesn't it yeah
mean girls the mean guy the me girl girl
yeah yeah
i think we should say uh kaya
she's on a bachelorette party is that
right to that will i say that
she wants us to say that
celebrating her
upcoming marriage well okay too late now
sorry
so yeah this is the move we're expecting
uh one of these mean girls maybe to push
forward this pawn um another one very
logical one would be this pawn it looks
like you're giving away some dark
squares but you do open up your bishop
you do also tie down black's rook
because one of the ideas for black might
be to swing the rook across now if the
rook swings across you can actually open
up a file for your queen and rook
um so yeah i'm expecting definitely um
if we go back one of these pawns to push
i don't think this one yet but either
this one sorry one square and then
up the board or maybe maybe the f pawn
is also very good the f pawn it makes a
lot of sense if you can
get the bishop into the game and uh you
know try to attack like that but magnus
having a big thing and we saw yesterday
he did a similar thing he had a very
long think when he's playing i think sam
shanklin and he came up with a really
clever idea didn't you i think it was
queen queen g4 in that game to to re and
after that he he won very easily he did
nothing he did a nothing move that
seemed to get under sam shanklin's skin
and then suddenly sam shanklin tried to
punish that move and it was
just terrible because he had created
weaknesses and problems for himself so
i mean at all levels i noticed i gained
100 200 points when i realized doing
nothing is actually i think half the
time the best idea in chess you provoke
your opponent to make blunders
i don't win my games because i play
flashy moves i can't remember any flashy
moves i play i just provoke the mistakes
and that's what magnus is so good at
yeah i mean there's not many other plans
as well i can see that white can do here
you can't really play on the queen side
you can't move many of your pieces over
there the bishops they can't really go
anywhere
so you have to really try to play uh on
the king side i think here's the own
area of the board i mean what other
plans can you do i'm just wondering guys
magnus's webcam has disappeared we
haven't seen uh any live shots of him
for a few minutes and now he's been
thinking for nearly four minutes is he
disconnected is magnus connected
to the game big question is it i believe
that magnus was disconnected from the
webcam because he had such a blurry
image i'm not quite sure but he was
having trouble with his
his streaming for a while there okay so
he is thinking he's not actually
disconnected from the game but four
minutes thought on this position
it's like simon says you have to push
one of the pawns there's not much else
to do yeah
what what can black deal now i mean we
talked about white's plans here i mean
is there anything you can see that black
can do to create some frets obviously
you know when you're playing chess if
you want to improve your position but
you want to create some nuisance for
your opponent can the black knight maybe
uh re-root itself okay he's gone for the
more um
full frontal attack there yeah and uh
simon you mentioned black's plans i was
about to suggest this one black's queen
slides across one square
i think the simple plan is to get greedy
go and grab a pawn black's knight and
queen both looking at white's a pawn i'm
not really sure that's a relevant pawn
it costs black a lot of time to go and
take it but black's knight if it does
capture the white pawn on a4 then it
does get offside
it will at least force magnus to try and
initiate some play he can't just take
all the time in the world now if he's
about to go down a pawn
so yeah vidit creating threats and maybe
a small trap in the position as well
that i've just spotted so
if we do jump in white did push this
pawn forward black's queen sliding
across as we mentioned eyeing up this
pawn and magnus moves his bishop if he
defended this pawn i think a big mistake
not just uh strategically here blocking
in his own rook but tactically because
suddenly which pieces are undefended for
white this one and how many pieces are
lined up against it it's quite a lot so
black could actually play knight takes
pawn attacking the queen and if the pawn
recaptures then this bishop at the
bottom of the board falls uh also
attacking this rook so
that's one don't get greedy don't just
protect pawns
don't forget about your loose pieces
magnus of course doesn't forget about
them and instead of pushing this pawn
which would be a losing blunder he
brings his bishop out
and counter-attacking against this wheel
surprised by that move actually
for the primary reason that if black
were to take the pawn that's up for
grabs
say
i mean suddenly the b2 pawn looks a
little bit vulnerable and if the knight
gets to that square then it can target
the defender of the c2 pawn yeah and
it's like it's like dominoes here uh for
example you bank if you're right if for
example even if i don't know just uh to
show the white pawn steps forward if
black can eliminate this defender this
defender actually holds together all of
white's pawns imagine this bishop if it
drops then the pawn next to it will drop
then the pawn next to it will drop and
and so on the one this is like a chain
they all connect they all defend each
other it's a little bit worrying for
magnus actually this position i mean uh
i i know i was getting very excited but
black has played it very well i think
and he's managed to create this counter
play and he's he's doing stuff on the
queen side now so you've got to you've
got to find a way to deal with it i
don't know how i don't really like what
he's done at all if you play bishop
takes pawn it's easily blocked black
just pushes a pawn hits your bishop and
next move this b2 pawn will drop so yeah
it's not going to be a very good sales
pitch is it for the course if he loses
with it
you know yeah but he didn't play
according to you he didn't no but no one
cares
when they look at it they're like you
know and this is one thing you find
actually a lot in chess databases that
people only look at the results
they don't look at the position so even
if someone's completely winning out the
opening if they blunder later on uh you
know no one cares about the opening
really interesting move there from
magnus because we talked about on person
earlier today
sometimes uh
me i know a lot of players as well we
just forget about moves if they allow on
pass on and this one wasn't even on my
radar i've to admit
i've got to say this pawn push allowing
black to play on passant um the whole
idea is that white's bishop at the
bottom of the board the white light
squared bishop on d1 is attacking
black's knight now
so
maybe maybe there's no time for black to
do anything vivid is confused i'm
confused there's so many options for
black
but what creativity from magnus and we
have to jump back in because this pawn
push so unexpected we were all looking
at this pawn or maybe the king's side
but magnus pushing this guy forward has
unleashed this discovered attack and on
passant here may be possible but it does
allow bishop takes knight and at least
temporarily white would win a piece
attacking the black queen in the process
i mean this is still super complicated
black can counter attack by pushing his
pawn
blacks down a piece but he's attacking
two bishops at the same time maybe he'll
win his piece back it's complicated but
if he doesn't play this um for example
and i was about to say if he jumps
forward with his knight taking the spawn
then there's a risk this knight gets
trapped behind enemy lines white's
bishop now under fire is about to move
i'm not sure exactly where but uh next
turn white will try and trap this knight
um
maybe it can just run back though maybe
the knight does have an escape route
back at the side of the ball maybe you
should keep an eye on the uh that
escaped square so going back uh maybe
this square yeah it feels a bit shaky
though somehow
it does i was wondering whether black
could kind of get creative and actually
start sacrificing
the knight black can give up at night
for a bunch of pawns but instead magnus
has gone in an opposite direction he
brought his bishop this way and actually
uh indirectly trying to attack the queen
so for example now if black does try and
evacuate the knight from uh from no
man's land then suddenly white's pawn
will step forward this is an attack
against the queen and wow it's really
livening up now black is throwing
everything at white's pawn chain
trying to trade off pawns here but again
question is what happens if white pushes
forward maybe with his pawn in the
center attacking the queen or what
happens if white takes this pawn with
his bishop attacking the rook attacking
the knight
chaos and i mean the evaluation bar says
it's all going in magnus's favor that
means there's a strong move right now
but so much choice and uh only five
minutes to choose
not easy
okay he does take this pawn double
attack
remember attacking this knight and
attacking the rook with your bishop
maybe it's just very yeah i'm quite
surprised uh especially vidic has been
moving so quickly over the last couple
of moves because uh
i think this the last couple of moves
was maybe the critical position
somewhere for the whole game and if he's
just moved into a very bad situation
then
very bad time management on his hands
because there was it was so many other
options that
vidic could have uh could have tried and
i'm struggling to see what he plays here
i mean he's got two pieces attacked
there's a problem he just missed this
move i mean
he should have moved slower then it's
not such a hard move to miss you know
it's like you know you you take a pawn
with your bishop look at his camera i
mean he's
he was shaking his head he leaned back
and frowned
yeah he's quite cool and karma collected
uh did it
yeah it's very strange very strange
the speed he was moving i think
also it's quite uncharacteristic because
he does struggle in end games very
simple positions fit it i think his feel
is maybe uh not quite as good as some of
the top players like magnus but
tactically normally he can hold his own
against these types of players normally
he's very good at calculation
is is there a way to kind of maintain
that knight so the first move that i'm
thinking is okay first of all you can't
do any defense so that means counter
attack um maybe attack the rook you know
jettison the b pawn okay so uh in the
current position
yup it's a double attack as we mentioned
black's rook and knight
both under fire so counter attack push
this pawn forward
um attacking the white rook but what if
the white rook moves for example
um actually maybe you'll write ivanka um
the white rook if it moves back then
suddenly the black knight can come out
gaining time in the process against the
white queen uh so maybe this pawn just
has to be removed maybe it has to be
captured yeah it's a very nice position
the night is out
and still
you know the yeah the operation was a
success but the patient still died you
know it looks terrible
certainly and there's also a real
problem with this e pawn in the center
of whites moving and yeah and just going
for the king side attack uh at the right
moment this this could be
really strong uh combined with the f
pawn moving even i mean for example i'm
not sure how to show it because black
has too many uh
pieces to defend for for example if you
just move your rook but yeah there's
always going to be ideas of opening up
this discovered attack against the queen
and vivid decides it's desperate times
desperate measures are called for and um
just to go back a couple of moves here
after the white bishop
left forward black's knight under attack
we've been highlighting it a few times
so it gave itself up you might as well
if you're about to lose a piece give it
give it up for as many pawns as possible
and after the white rook took this
knight suddenly at least black has a few
scary pawns for magnus to deal with
and uh okay lots of choice do you move
your rook away from the attack or do you
just snack on this black rook first you
could just capture this black rook we
could see a really weird pawn structure
um that's been the theme of today and
then you could run away with your bishop
now and what do we call these triple
pawns drunk porn
the irish pawns i think is their you
know official name actually so yeah
and interesting material and balance
here because the evaluation bar says
magnus is got a big advantage but okay
yes he's got an extra bishop but these
three pawns they are
uh kind of compensation maybe it's just
that they can't push forward
uh so bishop and three pawns worth
roughly the same but maybe the bishop is
superior here just looks completely
willing to fight to me
looks totally winning put the bishop
back in front of the pawns and and you
know enjoy yeah i mean i i
i don't know i can't see i can't see how
black can survive that position but yeah
so magnus has this
so he's wow he's gone for a while he's
gone for a
really crazy move there oh how is this
on his radar this is why the top players
are so good um because we were all
looking at this rook or maybe uh running
away from the attack white's rook under
fire but magnus has ignored both of
those ideas and pushed forward and he's
hoping for example that uh black takes
his pawn with his bishop because now
it's a double attack we mentioned this
attack against the queen discovered
threat and now the black bishop will
drop off next move but
i mean so much to calculate we have the
drunken pawns for three pawns in the
middle of the board and not just that we
have a double agent white pawn taking a
bishop but actually keeping the black
king pretty safe white's pawn maybe
doesn't even want to be there and uh two
black rooks under attack let's go back
to the players it's just complete chaos
right now and uh is this a little bit
about that mania we were talking about
earlier
good mania it's good mania for someone
i'm not sure who i think vidit he kind
of found himself in a situation he had
to just let loose and uh just had to
make it chaotic and wild the position
but
magnus
okay taking this pawn surprising but
very surprising because now you can go
queen takes pawn check maybe it's just
too hot at his place because i'm looking
at uh here we see a v that has 29
degrees at home but
magnus has 25 degrees with the earthings
i think they're blowing off some steam
right now
definitely and we do know that magnus
likes his rooms very very warm when he
plays often 25 26 degrees and
in norway that's uh almost a record but
okay the current position it has finally
become less wild it's clarified a bit
white has an extra bishop but black has
two pawns in return
it's all about whether black can hold
off uh the white army and just create a
fortress maybe a blockade on the dark
squares but
it feels like a distant dream at this
moment
i mean the problem is is that white
simply has one extra piece to attack and
the main target
is actually that pawn sitting on a light
square the f7 pawn yep
so for example if white's bishop which
doesn't look great right now if it does
re-root
we could see that happen right now
magnus retreating the white bishop and
say we get a
sorry about that guys say we get a
situation like this the white bishop and
the white rook will be attacking some
pawns and as ivanka said white has an
extra piece with which to attack and
black's pawns are going nowhere black's
two pawns
okay this exact maneuver has happened on
the board um also very logical the uh
yeah the black pawns are just targets if
anything
yeah i i don't see vinit saving this one
i mean he's got two pawns for the bishop
i mean luckily uh uh vidit has pawns in
one bunch which is actually which is
actually good because all the pawns can
guard each other
which is uh you know very very very
useful for some defense but i think
magnus's piece is going to swing round
he's going to he can swap queens at any
moment uh i'd i would have thought
magnus just going into an ending where
he'll be a piece up as well and well vid
is going to have to do an amazing
defensive job here to to hold this this
position yeah and uh but one thing i do
have to say is actually if but it were
to exchange of rooks
it's not that easy for the queen and
bishop to combine
on the dark squares and so they will
have to work their magic on the light
squares and again if black can if it's
successful yeah then uh you know they
have things like perpetual jacks in the
air yeah i mean you just keep the rooks
on the board i mean i i think it's
always worth when you're in these kind
of situations to just think which pieces
is it worth exchanging and which pieces
do i not exchange and as white's kind of
in control because he has that pressure
against that pawn that he's attacking
with a bishop um i i don't think he
needs to worry about that i mean let's
say you you move the rook attack the
pawn swap the queens off it's got to be
winning sure swapping the queens off i
don't think is that okay so he's moving
the bishop back now so i think what he
said and this is this is a typical
magnus i would not play this move but
what he said is i've created a weakness
uh in front of the white queen because
you can't defend that pawn with another
pawn now so i'm just going to move my
bishop back and attack that weakness of
my rook i mean it's really delicate
and nice nice maneuvering there
very very nice play uh and i don't see
how that pawn's gonna now paul may just
drop uh the black pawn and then he's
only got one pawn for the piece so that
can't be enough
okay all right okay first he's attacking
the black f7 pawn next black king black
has to defend that with his rook
um yeah what does magnus do with his
bishop
i thought his bishop was going to go to
that square where the queen's gone that
made a lot of sense then activate the
rook but um we've been for quite a long
game here i mean i'm less pessimistic
about black's choice black's chances
maybe
um i do think there's some drawing
chances
black's queen is just so strong and if
the queens do come off
white is running out of pawns i mean it
should be winning for white of course
with best play but a long way to go
what is vidic thinking about though he
has to just use his rook and defend his
pawns the black queen can't defend the
f7 pawn you don't want to touch your own
pawns
near your king you don't want to weaken
the black king any further and does
black kind of huddle into a shell and
put the rook next to the king or should
the rook maybe step keep its line and
move to the a7 square where
could be loose you know
i know i know it always matters but how
much does it matter right now with the
five minutes versus one minute on time
yeah yeah i think at some point it's
gonna become a real problem i mean maybe
not now because it's not so complicated
but at some point things always get
complicated and that's when you need to
have that extra time uh there will be a
moment where magnus sets the trap or
kind of forces visit to calculate and
having less than a minute
uh it's going to be tricky for him to
deal with that it's going to be tricky
for him to handle yeah
okay so i'm still trying to work out
magnus's plan though uh maybe he's just
doing a little bit of maneuvering around
uh for the time being until until he
works out the way to to go forwards i
mean it's not as easy as i first thought
um you've got to try to attack some
weaknesses but the only real weakness
well there's two weaknesses in black's
position but they're both uh well
defended uh one both can be defended by
the brook here yeah um so it's not that
straightforward do you exchange queens
ivanka well you know i
somehow or other i do feel that maybe
magnus can have some fun before taking a
committal decision of like exchanging
queens or exchanging any pieces
whatsoever i'm just thinking you know
maybe white needs to start to activate
the work
and put it on the b line and
then the rook and the bishop can start
harassing the queen from the fifth row
yeah and maybe even bring the rook down
to the seventh as well you could try to
try right i mean it's a really good
strategy that when you when you are
trying to win uh before you make a very
committal decision like exchanging
queens you try everything else you can
even
if you can kind of realize that those
tries are not going to result in in
really turning any goal um you just put
your opponent under little different
bits of pressure if it doesn't worsen
your position so i like that yeah
there's no rush to exchange queens okay
guys i think it's
i think it's time to make a prediction
here do we think white's going to win
as it's magnus and i think the position
should be winning yes
oh yes
yes
that was
if i get to voice an opinion as well i'm
excited just to be able to voice it but
but i i i always enjoy a good battle
here i'm hoping for a good finish where
vita can actually put up some
counterplay and we could have an
enjoyable
late game that was a really boring
answer wasn't it i mean
[Laughter]
coming up to the seventh rank okay i
think this one's going to be winning for
magnus sooner or later but i was going
to say i think it's going to be quite a
long game still so how many moves
i'm going to say 100 just because i'm a
scientist
but it's 38 moves already it feels like
they've played like 50 moves but they
haven't eight okay i'll go 80. i'll go
yeah i'll be a long one
it's definitely going to depend upon
view it because we know that magnus is
not going to start pushing here
regardless so
it's uh so what moves we got okay so
we've got a hundred eighty no i i'm
going to say lower than that actually
i'm gonna say oh especially after this
last minute after this last movie
exactly oh you're getting more
information every move it changes quite
a bit you declared your intentions too
come on hurry up get you moving let's
see how big it responds no you can't
just drag it out you've got to decide
yeah okay
70. okay i was saying i was hoping for
good counter play i don't know if i
necessarily believe in good counter play
so i'm going to say 61. see if you went
69 you cover all those numbers
but 61 is a good good bet i think as
well actually so i think you're gonna be
closest probably because this last move
by magnus it has changed things i
thought okay the queens were gonna come
off
the the black pieces would be able to
fight off the white army for a long time
with those two extra pawns but suddenly
white is about to win one of those pawns
and can i just push in here gwen jones
has won his first match and his or her
first game rather they're now playing
matches here but he's wanted against one
of the guys on top david anton brilliant
oh very good fantastic
yeah that's that's that's good to hear
yes i mean it's horrible when you're
having a horrible tournament you know
one it just feels like gold doesn't it
when you get a win it's like oh thank
goodness
and often sometimes it can be just what
you needed and they can be enough to
kind of launch a few other victories
and i did also see some stats uh by ty
our numbers guy um just before today and
david anton had 96 chance of qualifying
for the knockouts so
yeah uh we're celebrating going but yeah
yeah sure david anthony he's had a great
tournament i'm sure he'll
still do well but i heard you say
yesterday simon that once kwayne wins a
game here he's gonna he's gonna roll
he's gonna get into rhythm yeah i think
so like you know like ivanka mentioned
you kind of need that uh sort of just uh
it's it's really quite an emotional game
chess you know like uh like a lot of
things you is confidence you get that
first win and the way that gwain plays
you can just lift him to calculate
better so yeah so we might see uh i hope
many more wins from gwen in the next
rounds so next round is black against uh
dingley wren so that's going to be
interesting though okay that's a tough
one
right here still play the king's indian
which he's done the chesapeal corsan so
his speciality
and the signs are aligning you know the
prize for the quiz of the day is gawain
jones lifetime repertoire of the kings
indian it is a really good cause i mean
i know i know i have to really say that
i can't say it's rubbish but it is
actually a really good course i mean all
the chessable courses are great because
they're checked so thoroughly and i know
that because the amount of checking my
courses have been through it's intense
so they're all great but gwen's courses
is special he he gives that great
opening great justice 17 seconds for
vidit the clock is ticking down he needs
to make a move what is he going to play
ticking down to move 61. yeah oh and and
max five seconds and there's a pawn up
for grabs you need to defend that pawn
nope he can't do that yeah so he's lost
to pawn and the queens have come off now
it's four versus three on one side of
the board this one is winning for white
still
if all the pawns disappear then brooklyn
bishop versus rook is technically a draw
so uh vidiq now he does have some small
tiny glimmer of hope look out look how
happy magnus is he's got that big smile
on his face he's clearly
clearly very excited about how the
game's going here so uh
i mean
it's a good picture is that you know
i mean being surrounded by this great
british humor is one of the best places
i could have been right now
i love that comment simon
who is made me laugh
um okay so what is the winning plan for
white and how long will it take because
we're closing out of 61. sorry he said
61 ferris said 61. yes and what did you
say david i said a hundred just for the
sake of it
i you went 17 18. yeah right okay we're
looking good simon yeah yeah i think i
think we're getting nearer to to our
two i don't know i mean maybe you have
to push one of the pawns you don't
really want to exchange pawns off here
but i think maybe uh like an f pawn push
move the king in could you not have some
fun with the bishop first and improve
that one
maximum bishop can be improved and also
all of black's pawns lie on light
squares so you want to attack the base
of black's pawn chain that's this pawn
and this pawn is not protected by any
other pawn so at some point you would
love to kind of get a scenario where you
bring your rook up and for example if
black just waits and does nothing
somehow you want to bring your bishop
around and okay i'm just kind of being a
bit helpful here for black but if you
can get a situation like this where the
bishop and rook gang up against the base
of the black pawn chain then the rest of
the position collapses for black all of
the pawns disappear but uh yeah maybe um
maybe vidiq can fend off this this type
of idea for example in a situation like
this he can always bring his rook back
and stop the white bishop from
infiltrating he's gone for the f5 man
they've gone
wow okay really interesting by magnus
instead of going the long way round with
the bishop which i was hoping for to get
to move 100 uh he's pushed this pawn
forward it's edible in two different
ways if you take this way as black your
pawn in the corner drops suddenly white
gets harry the h-born another theme of
the day
and yeah suddenly you're breaking
through to this weakness as well so that
looks terminal but also if you play pawn
takes pawn then suddenly the white rook
is going to come up to the seventh rank
and
it's yes you've given up one pawn for
white but there's two big threats in the
position firstly white is threatening to
bring the bishop to the center attacking
this pawn but also attacking this rook
in the corner and a secondary threat for
example if black stops that is that the
white pawn is pushing forward and
breaking through thanks to the seventh
ranked pin
i think magnus has found the moment and
uh let's go back to vidit because five
seconds now
it could be maybe 61. it could be you
know it's sort of a
that h pawn is going to surely just win
the day now i mean uh
eight seconds
now you've created a second that's the
dream yeah black has to huddle up no
not
does this one work
he wants to trade a set of pawns but it
looks like the white rook can go up to
the seventh rank with a check maybe i
mean can you just is that a winning rook
and pawn ending even often you can
yeah often you can give up material to
to getting to an ending that you know is
winning and it looks very close to being
winning with the white king i'm just
thinking of a variation here i mean
we're probably going to see a move on
the board anyway but a key line is the
rook checks the king the king has to go
away from defense of the pawn have to go
to attack the bishop only square and you
have to now calculate pawn takes pawn
because it's a very concrete and forcing
variation black has to take the bishop
you push the pawn on creating another
big threat only one defense the rook
comes back
and
i was wondering now if you're in time to
move your king in here which is very
close to winning but
i'm not sure if it's this is if this
wins you play it so this is why magnus
maybe black and hold by the king going
back and just blocking this square just
uh maybe yeah maybe just in time but
you're right simon this is exactly
what's what magnus is calculating right
now magnus would love to just take this
pawn create a pass pawn of his own but
maybe he's not in time maybe he needs to
save his bishop first and there we go he
does save his bishop at least now black
gets this kind of cluster of pawns um
these three yes some of them will drop
after white's last move dropping the
rook back pinning and winning this pawn
but
if now vidic can trade off the rook
somehow it's a distant dream but if he
can kind of make the rooks disappear
from the board even if he loses these
three pawns if you're all the
highlighted pieces now if they all drop
off the board it's actually a draw
because uh a white bishop on light
squares alone and a pawn that promotes
on dark squares cannot win black's king
will just go and hide in the corner and
there's no way to evict it so uh some
hope for vidic
maybe definitely some hope um i have to
confess i actually had
this end game with the rooks and black
didn't have any pawns and it took me
forever
to win it because you know black kept
offering a trade of rooks they were
staying stalemating opportunities for
black and i just had to be so careful
even without these two pawns it's not
easy right not an easy not an easy win
maybe the pawns kind of help white in
some ways you often get that these
endings are
black wants to keep checking the white
king but sometimes the pawns get in the
way so you know off checks towards the
white king which you could see
potentially uh potentially here
in some in some cases for example now i
think a simple winning plan for white is
just bringing the bishop forward pushing
this pawn at the right time and
there we go magnus is about to maybe win
one pawn and then push his own pawn
simultaneously it looks like he's
getting closer and uh there we go we're
going to get the exact same game you've
mentioned there ivanka all of the black
pawns are about to drop off if we rush
forward to the current position who's 63
so it's get closing in on 71. yeah but
um i was 70 right 70 60 so 61 has gone
yeah 61 is gone yup okay 61 is gone
you're 70 and i'm 80 so okay
could see some sturdy defense maybe from
vidit
100.
i'm thinking i'm thinking you know i
made a meal
and the poor and the thing was that
people were waiting for me as well and
they were like yeah she's going to win
and within five moves and then like 50
40 moves later i was still at it
just tossing it out there it's so far
out of the
five games we see here it's all decided
um
it's uh also orientaria wins against von
forest which is pretty big in the scheme
of things
and how did eric hansen sorry i'm just
having a look because obviously eric was
bouncing back wasn't he into the
tournament yeah he's uh he's still
playing
still playing okay right oh really ten
cent game there against prague maybe
fizzling out to a draw um meanwhile
magnus he's forced the black king out of
the corner that's the first step
now the black king not blockading in the
dark square in the corner
i think it's move 68 i mean resigning
designing here would not be a bad option
i feel like you're playing magnus cast
in the mean light you know there's no
almost stalemate though if the black
rook wasn't on the board it would be a
draw and stalemate but the problem is
you can't give up your black rook and uh
i mean you can't force white to take
your black work and i think we're about
to see vidic has he just resigned he has
done 68 move 68 well done so 69 was
would have been a great a great answer
there for 68 yeah
and uh yeah magnus showing his class
taking the in-game win